merci je remercie eric woerth d'avoir
dit tout à l'heure il fallait qu'on
sorte des postures et des caricatures et
mon propos ici se situe exactement dans
cette danse est logique
avant de commencer je voulais casser un
mythe qui est assez tenace aujourd'hui
celui du lien entre l'électorat immigrés
et le vote à gauche comme moi il ya des
centaines et des milliers d'enfants
d'immigrés ouvriers qui votent à droite
et comme moi ils ont des milliers
aujourd'hui qui grâce à leur travail
grâce à des rencontres aussi qu'ils ont
pu faire dans leur vie ont pu réussir
mais s'il mode
ils votent moins systématiquement à
gauche aujourd'hui ils n'attendent pas
pour autant un discours sur mesure qu'on
devrait leur fournir car ils ont
exactement les mêmes attentes que tous
les français
nous pouvons aujourd'hui être une très
grande majorité une majorité large pour
que nous ayons conscience de ceux de
cette situation alors aujourd'hui la
question migratoire vous l'avez rappelé
pose est allongé majeur et elle pose la
question légitime de l'intégration pour
autant dire que l'intégration est en
échec aujourd'hui me semble quelque peu
excessif et je préfère parler de recul
de l'intégration de ralentissement de
l'intégration put que des chèques
aujourd'hui dans tous les domaines de la
vie économique social culturel
scientifique on a des cohortes
d'immigrés d'enfants d'immigrés qui ont
réussi quand on parle d'échec de
l'intégration qu'est ce que ça veut dire
combien d'ingénieurs combien d'avocats
combien scientifique de scientifique
pour dire que l'échec que excusez moi
que l'intégration a échoué quelques
chiffres et je vais aller très vite à
l'école à condition sociale égale les
enfants d'immigrés réussissent parfois
mieux que les autres enfants issus de
catégories populaires
ils sont moins nombreux que leurs pairs
à devenir ouvriers 42% contre 66% ce
sont les chiffres de 2012 les
descendants d'immigrés accède pour 50% à
la propriété ce qui est quand même le
signe qu'ils attestent l'attachement à
la terre et l'enracinement
de ses descendants d'immigrés ou
immigrés à leur société d'accueil
on compte aussi 65% de couples mixtes
donc parmi les descendants d'immigrés et
enfin selon une enquête de l'insee parue
en 2012
neuf enfants d'immigrés sur dix se
sentent français aujourd'hui
alors bien sûr il enquête ocde la marque
là l'a montré il ya quelques jours
43% des immigrés d'âge actif sont sans
emploi ce que l' enquête au cd le
rapport au cdja plutôt oublie de oublie
de dire c'est que lorsqu'on regarde
encore une fois les conditions sociales
deux de ces immigrés de ces natifs
on note que les enfants d'immigrés sont
certes plus au chômage mais ce n'est pas
aussi enfin le le cap n'est pas aussi
important que l' enquête ocde le montre
l'intégration est donc en marche mais
bien sûr personne ne peut le nier je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure il ya des
difficultés et il ya des reculs mais
plutôt que de parler d'échec je préfère
m'inscrire dans ce que disait un autre
amie nathalie kosciusko morizet dans
cette logique de sortie par le haut il
nous faut absolument sortir par le haut
et ne pas tomber dans ce discours de
déprime et de sinistrose qui nous fait
peur les difficultés dans le processus
de l'intégration aujourd'hui je pense
qu'elles tiennent davantage à la
ghettoïsation de nos territoires
une ghettoïsation à marche forcée qui
nourrit aujourd'hui le communautarisme
vous l'avez dit michel trappe michèle
tribalat 20 pour cent des immigrées et
15% de leurs enfants vivent aujourd'hui
dans les quartiers difficiles etc cette
concentration qui peut nourrir parfois
ce sentiment d'invasion et ce sentiment
de peur que peuvent avoir nos
compatriotes
c'est une situation qui est en pichet on
le voit jour après jour par les
revendications communautaires que ce
soit à l'école dans les hôpitaux dans
les entreprises ou encore dans les
piscines
alors comment est ce qu'on explique ces
reculs aujourd'hui comment est ce qu'on
explique qu' on a
plus en plus de mal à s'intégrer dans
notre pays tout simplement parce que
depuis ces dernières années on a cessé
de flatter les différences on a acté
l'idée d'une société multiculturelle
pour mieux à signer les populations à
leur adresse et à leur identité
plutôt que de promouvoir la mixité
sociale
on a préféré lutter contre les
discriminations
en plongeant ces populations qui sont
souvent française dans l'idéologie
victimaire de l'exclusion la politique
communautariste de la gauche
encore récemment avec la loi qui prévoit
les actions de groupe le culte permanent
de la mémoire ou de la repentance me met
aujourd'hui très mal à l'aise et je ne
suis pas la seule dans ce cas
comme tant d'enfants d'immigrés elle me
dérange pourquoi parce qu'elle fabrique
du ressentiment contre la france elle me
met mal à l'aise parce qu'elle a
inventée en quelque sorte ce concept
d'islamophobie qui fait qu'on ne peut
plus débattre des questions d'islam
aujourd'hui l'islam au pot
l'islamophobie qui n'est même plus
justifiée dans les faits un chiffre 2 %
seulement des plaintes pour
discrimination à la religion qui ont été
recensés par le défenseur des droits ont
été publiés aujourd'hui donc c'est un
chiffre extrêmement extrêmement faible
le recul de l'intégration et de ces
blocages enfin s'explique aussi par le
choix des politiques publiques
je vous donne juste un exemple en 2008
et j'étais dans le gouvernement pour les
lits mettre en place
on a mis en place ces internats
d'excellence et on est allé chercher les
enfants
quelle que soit leur origine les enfants
qui avaient un potentiel avec les
cordées de la réussite on a lutté contre
les freins à l'accès aux formations
supérieures et aujourd'hui on a cassé
tout cela tout ce qui permettait à tous
ces enfants d'origine modeste de
s'extraire de leur condition sans parler
du discours sur l'école qui est
aujourd'hui en voie de très mauvais
signaux alors oui l'intégration dans la
société française est en recul ce qui
nous oblige aujourd'hui apporter un
message d'espoir je pense qu'il nous
faut construire des chemins qui nous
font je le disais sortir par le haut
pour
v les freins à l'intégration et pour que
le communautarisme ne devienne pas la
règle en france nathalie encore elle
m'excuse disait ce week-end au touquet
qu'il fallait changer d'idée il fallait
avancer des idées neuves des idées
innovantes pour 2015 et pour 2017
elle évoqua son fils directeurs celui de
la liberté et je suis d'accord avec elle
sur ce concept de liberté qu'on doit
absolument mettre en avant pourquoi
parce que c'est la liberté qui
privilégie l'individu et qui accorde une
chance à tous quelles que soient les
origines au delà de toute religion et au
delà de tout dogmatisme c'est la liberté
qui inculque l'envié de réussir et je
terminerai par ceux-ci donc en disant
que si nous voulons rassembler au delà
de notre famille politique nous devons
rester nous mêmes républicains
fidèle à nos valeurs et c'est ce qui a
suscité mon adhésion auprès des
républicains
et voilà donc nous devons absolument
rester nous mêmes
et comme l'a rappelé tout à l'heure eric
woerth à ne pas être dans les postures
ou dans les caricatures je vous remercie